As if the
first ever indictment
of a former president
wasn't enough to digest.
This week,
Tennessee pushed the political world
into a further tailspin.
The GOP dominated House
voting to expel two young
Democratic lawmakers
because they had taken part
in a gun control protest.
It didn't escape.
Notice that Representatives
Justin Jones and Justin Pearson are black
while they're white collar.
Gloria Johnson
also protested,
but she survived being kicked out
by one vote.
And joining us now to talk about
this is Republican
strategist, CNN political analyst
Alice Stewart,
and CNN political commentator
Bakari Sellers,
a former South Carolina state legislator.
Bakari.
I have to start with you first,
because I got to wonder
what would have been like for you
to be in the thick of this?
How did we get here?
That's a good question.
And how would I have felt to be
in the thick of this?
I don't think that at the period of time
I like that from 2006 to 2014,
the temperature was what it is today.
The fact is, I think Republicans
in the Tennessee General
Assembly
just shot themselves in the foot.
They didn't want these young black men.
They probably looked at them
as these young colored boys
be able to speak up
and use their use their words
and use their courage.
And do the things that they felt
should be done.
But yet and still they made them martyrs.
They put them on a pedestal.
Now, everybody knows just an injustice
And the fact they did it
without any regard
to their white colleague, Gloria,
who's actually an ally,
who is a hero herself.
It just shows you what this was about.
This was about putting two young Negroes
in their place.
And I think it backfired
and let in 1966 and Julian Bond.
And Alice
that state
legislator that
Bakari just mentioned Gloria Johnson
she said yes
because of the color of my skin
that she was spared and the other two
lawmakers were not
when it comes to expulsion
Let me ask you, Alice.
The Republican Party in Tennessee
they hold a supermajority
in the General Assembly there.
Is this what you wanted to see this week
from state lawmakers there in Tennessee.
Was this a mistake?
Did they go too far?
What do you think
It is not what I wanted to see.
Yes, they made a mistake and yes,
they went too far.
I think this absolutely
could have been handled
by just censuring these legislators
and potentially maybe removing them
from their committee assignments.
And they certainly would have
gotten the message.
And I've spoken
with one of the
representatives that made this decision,
and they said it was very difficult.
It was a very emotional day.
But when they looked at the footage
and talked with people
that were there
on the day of these protests,
they saw the two justins
acting a little bit more aggressively
than the woman who was not expelled
from the legislature.
They saw them going up into the balcony
and inciting the crowd and really
furthering the intensity
of these protests.
And look,
I give all three of them
great courage
for standing up
for what they believe in and standing up
for what
they want to see
in terms of enacting legislation.
But many people know
and Bakari knows this,
having been in the legislature,
in order to effect change
and have meaningful legislative outcomes,
you need to have common ground.
You need to have
communication,
you need to have civil discourse
on these issues.
And in order to change legislation,
you have to change
hearts and minds
and make meaningful legislation.
And I truly believe if these three had
tried to have meaningful conversations
with all of the legislature,
about meaningful ways
to reform gun violence,
that could have been helpful
and certainly would have made progress.
Unfortunately,
this is still the first of what I see
many, many more conversations
from the three of these people.
And Bakari,
what do you see
in terms of this
being an assault on democracy?
At the state level in Tennessee?
Did you view it that way?
I know a lot of folks
in the Democratic Party,
they see sort of a rollback of
I guess, democratic
procedures taking place in statehouses
across the country.
Is that what you did?
You see some of that
at play in Tennessee as well?
I did, Jim.
And, you know,
people always want to say
I mean, as soon as we get out this office
segment, people are going to say,
what are you
why are you playing the race card?
On social media is going to go crazy?
Well, you have to understand the dynamics
of where we are in the South.
You have to understand
the dynamics of these
these young black men
attempting to speak their truth to power.
You have to understand
the dynamics
of what's at play in Nashville,
where you have
these kind of democratic epicenters
of economic
empowerment in Memphis
where these men represent.
And so when you
when you put all of these things together
and you see the fact
that the first thing they wanted to do
was shut them up.
The first thing they wanted to do
was tell them that,
boy, you can't speak no more,
then you realize where we truly are.
I mean, you think about Josh Hawley.
I mean,
people want to talk about decorum.
You think about Josh Hawley
raising his fist of power
as he walks by insurrectionist.
And Josh Hawley
today is still a United States senator
from the great state of Missouri.
Like people never thought
about removing him from office.
But we had young
people gunned down in a school.
Let's put all of this in the context
we had young people, babies
gunned down in a school.
And these young people, these young black
boys, men, excuse me, decided
they were going to
speak their truth
to power
about not having any more
young babies gunned down.
And yet they eject them from their seats.
And so there's something else
at play here.
And I think what's at play is race.
I think power dynamics are at play.
And I think the erosion of democracy,
as you said, Jim, is at play.
And until we truly deal
with these things,
Donald Trump
showed us that you can use
racism as political currency.
You can attempt to chip away
at a road democracy.
And then you can talk to people
however you want to talk to them
and still be politically successful
in this country.
That's the danger.
And that's why we understand
democracy is fragile.
And Alice
McCarthy brings up a good point.
Sure. Go ahead. Go ahead.
Now, if I could just say,
having worked in the state house
right across the border from Tennessee
in Little Rock,
in the governor's office,
and seeing how
legislative proceedings are carried out,
there are rules.
There are
there's procedural,
the quorum that is necessary
in order to make meaningful change
to represent people all across the state.
And the
those that I have spoken with
say when you violate those norms,
there needs to be consequences.
And we need to have order in order
to make change in these states.
And again,
I can't say
I commend these three
for standing up for what they want to do.
But the best way
to have meaningful change
and get back to the real topic at hand
is these six innocent lives
that were killed in the school shooting.
How do we prevent this from happening?
Let's hear from the Tennessee three.
Let's talk about red flag laws.
Let's talk about hardening targets.
Let's talk about school resource officers
about mental health.
All of these ideas
from legislators
across the state of Tennessee
in the country
are important
to have meaningful gun violence change.
But Alice,
I mean, didn't
Marjorie Taylor
Greene violate
some decorum
during the State of the Union speech
for President Biden
when she was shouting liar at him?
I mean, she's done this
a couple of State of the unions in a row.
And, you know, she wasn't kicked out
that.
Marjorie Taylor Greene is
on her own island
and she has been kicked off
committee assignments in the past.
And look,
I think there's a completely
there's a
slightly different scenario
when she inappropriately
and disrespectfully screams out
at the president of the United States.
I think that is absolutely,
completely wrong.
But this is a different situation,
in my view,
when you have legislators
that have disrupted
the legislative process
for nearly an hour
and were given the opportunity to say,
all right,
let's have conversations
and we won't do that in the future
when that didn't happen.
That's why
these legislators in Tennessee
made the decision they had.
All right.
Last word from you, Bakari.
Yeah, I mean, I think that I mean,
with respect to Alice and everyone else,
we saw John Lewis, the great John Lewis,
take a seat on the state
on the on the floor
of the United States Congress.
We see these acts of civil
disobedience happen all the time.
It's civil disobedience.
They broke no laws.
They committed no crimes.
They violated decorum.
In a general assembly,
committed acts of civil disobedience.
And yet you have lawmakers
who actually violate
real crimes,
commit DUIs,
who beat their wives, etc., etc.
and they still get a chance to sit.
So let's actually add
context to this
and understand what they did in
Tennessee was about
race, was about power,
and was about eroding democracy.
Shame on Tennessee.